aaron donald three-time defensive player
of the year something to damien clowney
aspires to be
assault charges have been filed now it's
not charges by prosecutors it's a
criminal complaint
we need to be careful on that
distinction they've yet to decide based
upon the information
provided by a man named vincent spriggs
that aaron donald
will be subject to any type of criminal
charge but spriggs claims that he
apparently bumped into aaron donald
pittsburgh out somewhere
early sunday morning late saturday night
and donald
beat the crap out of him for lack of a
better term broken arm
spriggs claims concussion spriggs claims
17 stitches spriggs claims near his
eye and in this day and age where
everyone's walking around with one of
these and surveillance cameras
everywhere
i assume that there will be some video
evidence of whatever it is
that happened to corroborate the claim
if there is any corroboration to be had
shireen so this is a potentially serious
situation for donald
and the rams have issued a statement
they're collecting information the
perfunctory statement that we see all
the time the league would have
jurisdiction under the personal conduct
policy
it's something that will will develop
over time and donald could face
criminal jeopardy civil liability and
also a suspension by the league
i don't know how it happened mike but i
saw the photos of that guy's eye swollen
shut he's an out of state or they
wouldn't say this attorney wouldn't say
exactly where it was from but that was
just a
nasty eye injury that he had uh with
this you could see the stitches in the
picture and
apparently had a broken nose and a
broken eye socket and
just a nasty picture however it happened
but you know the old saying mike nothing
good ever happens after midnight this
was at some point at an after hours club
between three and four a.m
and they were both kicked out and then
it happened on the street whatever the
altercation was they're looking for
video now as you said and there's
usually video of everything as we know
but this is the time as we talked about
mike that teams worry about their
players
because they're not always at the team
facility they're not required to be
there they're out they go out they they
party they have fun there's nothing
wrong with that but let's make sure that
you don't get in trouble don't get in
these types of
situations make sure you have a ride
home after you've been drinking
all those types of things they remind
their players this is when they worry
most mike
and the thing that guys who who have
physical violence at the core of what
they do
and and really anyone who's that age and
and you know you got the testosterone
you you know you get into a fight
there's a point where getting into a
fight will get you thrown in jail and
we'll get you on the hook for
potentially significant
civil liability because whatever damage
you
inflict whether you meant to or not
you're responsible for it and typically
your insurance
isn't going to cover it it's coming out
of your pocket so if you
bust up a guy's eye if you put him in
the hospital if you cause
extensive dental damage if you break his
arm anything like that the medical bills
are going to be your responsibility
compensation for that person's pain and
suffering is going to be your
responsibility it gets very expensive
very quickly
and it's a lesson that plenty of players
have earned or learned excuse me time
and again
and not just athletes but the thing is
if you're an athlete and you got the
money
they're more likely to come after you
it's somebody who doesn't have money
why waste the time but when it's
somebody like aaron donald there's
reason
to try to go get that compensation and
if he did it he should compensate
the gentleman involved for the the
injuries that he suffered
uh and it's it's that simple shireen and
you're right when players are left to
their own devices that's when teams
worry
because you have to trust that they're
always going to make good decisions
and sometimes it's not it's not a
significant percentage
it's just a few and aaron donald not a
guy that we'd peg for something like
this and it's innocent until proven
guilty and we don't know whether he did
it or not
but it's that small percentage that
attracts attention
and it makes players who don't get in
trouble look bad
yeah and and let's hope that you know
whatever happened that he works us out
and figures it out and
and uh maybe it didn't even happen and
that would be great if aaron donald
really wasn't even
involved in this but we'll find out as
this process plays out mike
but let me ask you this as an attorney
do you settle this thing
i mean he's still going to be subject to
the personal conduct policy of the nfl
but would you if you're in his situation
and you actually did
this would you just go try to settle it
with this man
absolutely absolutely write him a check
for for a fair payment
for what he experienced the damage that
you inflicted if you did it
if you did it if you didn't do it then
you know i mean
who knows at this point if there was
never an altercation
involving aaron donald if it was a case
of mistaken identity whatever the case
may be then you hold firm
but if aaron donald punched this guy or
shoved this guy or did whatever that
caused that damage
then you make it right you definitely
make it right and a lot of times that's
what avoids the criminal charges and and
you know
as we said in the context of the desean
watson case that we're going to talk
about in a second
justice comes in various forms and it's
the victim
of the wrongdoing that gets to pick the
justice that he or she wants and
sometimes it's enough
to get compensation for your injuries
and you no longer are motivated
to pursue criminal charges that could
happen as well so
yeah if i'm aaron donald and and i did
this
i am pulling out the checkbook
and i am apologizing profusely and i
am writing a check to make this right
for the gentleman who i injured if i did
it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports